september's playstation plus deals have
been revealed and so has some new
details for god of war ragnarok combat
brace yourself for a new month is upon
us and that means new free games games
that you're probably going to add to
your backlog and hopefully get around to
playing because there are some good ones
in here september's playstation plus
essentials lineup will include need for
speed heat towing and grand blue fantasy
versus this new batch of games will be
available starting september 6th and all
playstation plus subscribers regardless
of tier can claim the playstation plus
essentials lineup each month need for
speed heat is the latest entry not
including remasters in the long running
ea racing franchise it features a cool
night and day system in which you
complete sanctioned events by day and
illegal street races after dark toem is
a charming indie in which you play as a
young photographer in search of a
snapshot of the toeim phenomenon
unfortunately for ps4 players only the
ps5 version of tome will be available to
claim in september the third game in the
only one in this lineup i don't already
own is grand blue fantasy verses this
game is a 2.5 d fighter featuring
characters that first appeared in the
grand blue fantasy mobile rpg in 2014.
if you haven't already make sure you
claim the august freebies before they
leave playstation plus on september 6th
that lineup is 3 for 3 with absolute
bangers like yakuza like a dragon tony
hawk pro skater oneplus 2 and little
nightmares don't miss out and if you're
one of those rich kids with an extra
membership you can look forward to games
like death loop watch dogs 2 and
assassin's creed origins just to name a
few the super rich kids with a premium
membership have access to new classic
titles like the sly cooper collection
sly cooper thieves in time and most
importantly toy story 3 for psp for more
on the latest additions make sure you
watch our upcoming episode of the
playstation plus show now let's switch
gears a little bit to god of war
ragnarok a game that could be day one on
playstation plus extra or premium if
sony wasn't so
scared please don't blacklist me please
two of the lead combat designers for god
of war ragnarok have broken their
silence offering some insight on new
combat abilities for the former spartan
speaking with game informer sheth and
yeah have detailed some of kratos's new
combat techniques including the ability
to infuse both the leviathan axe and the
blades of chaos with enhanced elemental
properties depending on the weapon ice
for the axe and fire for the blades
doing so activates new weapon signature
moves for us to wake in for the axe and
whiplash for the blades which will
inflict massive damage on enemies as for
shields they'll play a larger role in
the combat scheme with new shield types
affecting how specific shields can be
used in battle some like the dauntless
shield are lighter but excel at parrying
while others such as the stonewall
shield are sturdier and more fit for
slower combat absorbing damage and
creating a shock wave that knocks
enemies down when enough damage is
absorbed chat and yeah also dive into a
new enemy type called grim a lizard-like
creature that stands on two legs sounds
a little bit like my ex
he gets it
no other new enemies were unveiled but
chef and yeah did say that areas will
repopulate with new enemies as the game
progresses so backtracking through an
area may reveal some new challenges i
need this game like yesterday let me
know in the comments what you've been
playing to hold yourself over until the
new god of war comes out and i'll see
you tomorrow
you